bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj oggi siamo su
amnesia è machine for peace che dopo 12
anni di sviluppo del videogioco è uscito
non ci posso credere
vabbè comunque era che volevo farlo da
secoli amnesia much for peace lo sapete
è vi giuro che finalmente iniziamo a una
goduria assurda perché non potevo più
aspettare
quindi direi di andare iniziano la
partita che dodici anni di attesa sono
stati abbastanza qui non vedo l'ora
d'iniziare ragazzi spero che sia
spaventoso almeno quanto il primo colui
che tra somma se stessi in una bestia si
sbarazza del dolore di essere un uomo
dottor samuel johnson
io mi sbarazzo nel dolore di essere poi
vj comunque penso sia lo stesso c'è uno
sfondo rosso bellissimo tra l'altro le
gambe spero papà ti prego non uccidermi
non so chi ti sta riferendo ma io non
sono tuo padre con che cos'è cos'è una
nuova discoteca ragazzi ci sento bene
skrillex il suo posto
[Musica]
ok va bene basta poi sembra una macchina
per cubetti di ghiaccio non so se ciò
azzeccato bello comunque bellissimo
fantastico forse è la fabbrica del della
giochi preziosi comunque ragazzi spero
che fosse papà papà che cazzo che di
papà non sono tuo padre
vabbè ci stiamo svegliando da qualche
parte non so dove già solo il fatto che
ci siamo svegliati non so dove significa
che questo è un horror coi contro maroni
chi è che ha chiudo la porta ragazzi
qualcuno ha chiuso la porta non so chi
c'è in teoria non dovremmo svegliarci
imposti senza sapere come ci siamo
arrivati però in tutti gli horror che si
rispetti non si inizia così a me sia
machine for peace ragazzi non vedevo
l'ora di vedere sta scritta sul computer
non ci posso credere
io ho veramente paura di che cosa stiamo
per andare a incontrare dove cazzo siamo
un risveglio che fa una pippa una notte
da leoni non so dove come ci siamo
svegliati qui non so che ci siamo
arrivati
tra l'altro ragazzi questo è lesto più
figo che abbia mai visto perché c'ha la
gabbia per proteggersi dall uomo nero di
notte questo mi servirebbe a me ogni
tanto che che ciò gli incubi va bene
mantieni mouse sinistro nuovi mouse per
usare la porta i comandi alla fine
poteva anche disattivarli perché a furia
di giocare ad amnesia league li sua
memoria
nei miei sogni vede un uomo ammanettato
in una pelliccia di jaguar e più matto
come un santo insanguinato ragazzi e io
mi ricordo sti dialoghi assurdi di
annese che non ho mai capito
ve lo dico adesso così per tutta la
serie lo sapete già se volete leggere le
note che ci sono in giro io le prende vi
lascio un secondo per scopare il video e
leggerle perché io di leggere sta roba
sinceramente non c'ho voglia perché sono
poi alla fine video esce troppo lungo
quindi nel caso vogliate leggerlo
stoppate il video poi riprendere quando
avete finito se volete leggerlo sono
fatte come me che ve ne sbatte altamente
il birillo dove siamo ragazze una c'è un
letto che fantastico ragazzi
io uscirei dico anche se no ma la
lanterna dove non c'è non c'è ancora la
lanterna proveniente da devo trovare è
lecito cagarsi addosso anche qui dentro
spero di sì
cos'è sento rumori molesti e ci abbiamo
appena iniziato non è ancora successo
nulla ma sento rumori che non mi
piacciono
comunque il cesso potevano evitarlo
anche perché non c'è il nulla invece di
buttarmi 18 direi che posso provare ad
andare avanti anche se non so dove sto
andando vado a caso dai ragazzi
vediamoli soliste scale prima cos'è
qualcuno è sentite qualcuno ha perso una
palla ho trovato un pallone non sa se
qualcuno vuole giocare con me ma non
sono disponibile al momento cosa è
successo
raga e ancora non è successo un cazzo ma
sir umani mi fanno rabbrividire
abbastanza comunque andiamo avanti di
qua perfetto la porta è chiusa
non so come questo no questo è stato la
genia ta assurda no vabbè la soffitta
hanno vinto con la soffitta hanno vinto
tutto sta arrivando un uomo cattivo è
veramente io sono fa vj non sono un uomo
cattivo cos'è ragazzi c'è qualcuno è
passato ho visto ho visto maledetto
stronzo ho già preso inutile che giochi
a nascondino con me ho già vinto
cioè per di in partenza se ci provi
comunque vabbè andiamo avanti non so
dove siano finiti la soffitta non è che
mi mi rassicuri così tanto cos'è questo
c'è un orsacchiotto ragazzi qualcuno è
interessato nostra kyoto lo rivendo a 2
euro e 50
amico mio ho trovato un orsacchiotto sei
per caso interessato e te lo passo dal
dal buco qui perché non ci passo io
spada che prova a far canestro nella
culla madonna mia michael jordan la
vendetta ragazzi comunque prova andare
avanti perché sennò cos'è questo hai
raccolto a questa è la lanterna premi f
per accenderla
ragazzi ci siamo stiamo per entrare nel
mondo di amnesia vero e proprio con la
lanterna ragazzi siamo veramente
beh direi che possiamo andare avanti
così con la lanterna è molto meglio
perché vedo già di più prima non vedeva
una mazza comunque c'è
mantieni mons ma li sai cosa inutile che
continuate ad a darmi consigli lo so già
ho giocato una media per secoli siamo
nascosti va o dio che ho preso anche è
inutile che scapito già visto anche per
te ragazzi e con fa vj non si può
giocare a nascondino è una partita persa
vabbè comunque io vado di qualche oggi è
inutile che accordi brutto stronzo dove
sta andando
siamo siamo dall'altra parte però qua ci
sono le culle una dormita me la farei
volentieri ma mi sa che non ci sto qua
dentro
noi andiamo aspettare che c'è lo sa
chiotto di prima che non so come sia
finito sul letto perché in realtà non
era caduto sul letto e questo è già
abbastanza inquietante comunque va beh
non provate a spaventarmi perché io no
un orsacchiotto a un orsacchiotto non ho
paura di dormirci insieme non sono il
tuo [ __ ] papa è inutile che continua
a gridare papa non sono io c'è ragazzi
qualcuno qua mi scambia per suo padre mi
dispiace ma non è così per buttare giù
lampadario ma non fa niente tanto
nessuno ha visto nulla se avete evitato
ragazzi c'è qualcuno che sta suonando il
pianoforte ci sentite un attimo io non
ho idea di chi cazzo si chiama devona ma
in qua e qua al pianoforte
cioè quanti piano facile o io
l'orsacchiotto l'ho buttato sul
lampadario e cioè lampadario non è
caduto quindi non sono stato io
ragazzi è accaduto un quadro saranno
stati i bambini di prima io non sono
stato ragazzi vedetevi correre meno per
caso che fate un casino della madonna
poi devo mettere a posto io
vabbè tra l'ato raga io non so cosa
qualcuno qua giocato a poker
spero che non siano i bambini se no è
una brutta cosa perché qua c'è un fucile
imi che lo posso prendere mio dio che
vado in giro col fucile non sarebbe male
cioè almeno con un fucile andrei sul
sicuro ma qualcosa mi dice che è
impossibile avere armi in amnesia la
portasse mi ha aperto le porte
semiaperte non mi sono mai piaciute
professione lo stesso un ai quattro
formaggi e una prosciutto grazie in
croce prezioso frutto dei cactus
dell'aquila aiuta spiega ma fu famille
cactus
no ragazzi chi è questo che sta parlando
al telefono il frutto del cactus cos'è
un insulto ma vabbè mi fa piacere
comunque sia non ho cactus mi dispiace
ma oggi è pieno di fucile
[ __ ] una leva mi chiami stavo
prendendo troppo bene pensavo di poter
staccare il fucile dal muro mio dio c'è
per un attimo ho veramente creduto di
poter usare un fucile in amnesia
possiamo farci un giro ragazzi offro io
vabbè cosa cosa l'ho aperto io questo
iron era una porta segreta o perspicaci
ragazzi
vabbè ci sono che cos'è che cazzo
senti beni ricorrere meno per casa per
che cosa fa dove cazzo andato non lo so
noi proseguiamo evitiamo i bambini che
corrono perché tanto cos'è questo belle
bellissime le foto tra l'altro
fantastico altro che poster
segue a questo il bagno c'è questo
questo è lo specchio del bagno io posso
guardare da dietro lo specchio c'è
questa questa è una cosa veramente
brutta ragazzi da troppo di storica c'è
posso osservare qualcuno mentre si lava
i denti fantastico o mentre si fa il
bagno doni in quest'epoca venire questa
era della ragione un altro un impero
ingrassato che in all'obesità pronto per
il salasso è ingrassato picchiano maggi
nutella mi sembra un po difficile
comunque vabbè contratto ragazzi
statista case è piena zeppa di passaggi
segreti va beh siamo usciti il bambino è
andato di qua comunque per la cronaca
dato sta crollando piccola
finito bene così ragazzi sta crollando
la casa e devono essere i bambini che
giocano a nascondino un modo un po
troppo rumoroso ragazzi smettetela di
fare casino che il papa fa vivi
sculaccia amo finché non mi spunta
nessuno e continua a correre i bambini
va ancora bene comunque va beh cazzo
siamo finiti adesso raga c'è un altro un
altro salone fantastico io non ho mai
capito ste case del 1800 come fanno
essere così enormi da questa parte papa
viene a vedere da questa da questa parte
dove chi è che ha poi chi ha parlato c'è
qualcuno che mi sta chiamando non so chi
è che succede la finiamo con queste
scosse di terremoto c'è ma possibile
nascosta ogni 40 ragazzi
smettetela di correre io non so che
cazzo di numeri sono questi non mi sta
piacendo laica che cosa succede
ho visto un flashback o cosa va beh
comunque qua qualsiasi cosa sia successa
ho visto dei bambini correre dall'altra
parte tavolo per due
vabbè è comunque le tavolate sono
piccole mi dicono va bene io non so che
cosa ci sto a fare ancora qui dentro
comunque se la casa non mi crolla e mi
fa piacere anche perché girovagando
cos'è un altro telefono bello non ho
capito bene
[Musica]
senta mi sono sbagliato ai quattro
formaggi era meglio mondays mi conosci
chi sei dove sono i miei figli questo
dovrei averlo detto io la vedo
intrappolati malus molto più sotto la
macchina e sudicia manomessa allagata le
paratie sono abbattute i bambini sono in
trappola se mi aiuterai posso aiutarti a
liberarli
ho capito che hanno ragazzi ho capito
tutto allora aspettate io sto comandando
effettivamente il padre di quei bambini
ripristina l'energia mando sgrena
l'allagamento è via via quei poderosi
motori dove devo andare
pronto pronto la mia pizza ragazzo non
ho capito bene allora
quello che io ho capito è che io mi sono
risvegliato in casa in casa mia c'è
questa è casa mia effettivamente dicevo
io secondo me sono il padre di quei
bambini li e li devo ritrovare come sta
dicendo sto tizio è questi che vedo sono
non sono veri e propri bambini ma sono
fantasmi
credo non lo so ragazzi io io ho tutto o
tutta una mia idea di trame che è una
cosa impressionante
cos'è non ci fosse una porta aperta ma
non ci posso arrivare va beh intanto io
me ne vado di qua perché non mi piace ma
ma se non aperto siamo siamo all'aperto
ciao ragazzi siamo usciti in amnesia il
primo non non si esce ma anche una volta
e qui siamo già aperto cioè bene o male
io mi trasformerò in spiderman e uscire
da scavalcare i muri però va bene
l'importante è che l'uscita la mia
trovato anche se non è una vera e
propria uscita comunque è anche c'è
ancora un altro porto perfetto permesso
io ho visto dei bambini correre non so
dove meglio visti correre siamo siamo di
nuovo qua ra qua ecco perfetto posso
passare ragazzi fermi c'è ma io non ho
capito perchè sti bambini fermi avete
anche chiuso il cancello ma che bastardi
cioè io non posso andare bene così non
posso raggiungere quei bambini di merda
perché amy si chiudono le porte di
giorno deve essere una figata assurda
abitare disco posto però di notte non lo
è tanto cos'è che cazzo ti guardi tu
smettila di fissarmi pappagallo
bruttissimo e ignoriamo i pappagalli che
mi guardano perché ci sono c'è un tapiro
perché ci sono capire ippopotami e orsi
in una stanza e ragni io quella teca
nola pro anche se so che non è vip così
posso accarezzare loro ragazzi
accarezziamo l'orso speriamo non si
sveglio cose dai cosa fa a si sposto
questo scelta dietro a mi sa che c'è un
passaggio segreto forse ho una roba asi
i fatti mio dio ragazzi fuori j
favi j.lo peggio di sherlock holmes
vabbè ho trovato un passaggio segreto
qualche diamo un attimo perché mi sto
pagando già addosso perfetto dove siamo
finiti ragazzi sono questa casa ci sono
più passaggi segreti che altro comunque
ringrazio di posto è cioè ricordiamoci
che siamo in una casa alla fine c'è mio
dio che cos'è cos'è sta roba
ho girato la valvola anche se non ho
capito bene a che serve
noi torniamo indietro qualcosa qualcosa
avrà fatto tipo la porta si sblocca non
lo so
si vede che ho acceso qualcosa indietro
non ne ho idea comunque noi a cosa
servono tutti sti passaggi segreti in
una casa ancora non l'ho capito
vabbè non culliamoci dei pappagalli di
pezza che si spostano da soli perché a
buggiano di mortacci sua mi sono
massacrato un ginocchio grazie mille
brutto presente non so chi c'è
dall'altra parte raga ma qualsiasi cosa
ci sia mi ha fracassato un ginocchio lo
spavento grazie
amo quando succedono queste cose porca
[ __ ] va bene facciamo finta noi non
avete visto nulla e ancora
effettivamente non ho visto nulla ma ho
sentito più caldi rei di andare avanti
dico perché ancora non ho visto la fine
del corridoio spero che ci sia è infatti
porto semiaperte raga quanto le detesto
ste porte non avete idea però vabbè ce
n'era un altro cesso c'è qualcuno ci
scommetto qualsiasi cosa e qui dietro
c'è qualcuno va bè un'altra vasca raga
io ancora non ho capito che cazzo e
prese 4 ho fatto
ragazzi oddio mica favi genova meglio
basta dopo questo mi do alla professione
di detective perché non ci sono eguali
ragazzi mio dio
vabbè comunque qua dentro di sicuro non
è che ci fanno le feste ai bambini
va beh spero che non ci siano passati i
bambini più che altro comunque andiamo
avanti di qua
un'altra valvola devo devo girare anche
questa presumo sia meno succederà
qualcosa forse ma le altre dall'altra
parte si la vedo ragazzi qualcosa ho
fatto non ho capito ancora bene cosa ma
di sicuro c'è qualcosa stormare ragazzi
paranormal allucci che cazzo è successo
ci sono
vabbè ho capito bene dei ragazzi che ho
incluso più l'episodio ovviamente anche
se siamo all'inizio giornale videogiochi
all'inizio non sono tanto porosi perché
devono calarsi nell'atmosfera ma
nonostante questo come primo episodio se
ne è saputo a cavare ugualmente quindi
ragazzi non vedo dare di continuarlo a
discapito del mio cuore perché con gli
infarti successivi di sicuro non me la
passerò bene comunque
ragazzi io concludo qui episodio 6 video
è piaciuto come al solito ha sciolto il
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come noi video trovate nella
descrizione
se non siete iscritti iscrivetevi e noi
ci rivediamo il prossimo vito bella
ragazzi
[Musica]